hallo leute heute geht es um ein thema
das viele von euch oder wahrscheinlich
alle von euch kennen und dieses thema
ist wie werde ich fließend im deutschen
oder überhaupt beim sprachenlernen
oft gibt es dabei ein problem ihr fangt
an eine sprache zu lernen und schnell
fangt ihr an sachen zu verstehen aber
sprechen ist trotzdem noch nicht so
einfach und in dieser zeit wo er noch
nicht so schnell sprechen könnt oder so
gut sprechen können wie ein
muttersprachler
da braucht ihr eine methode um das zu
überbrücken manche gehen in eine schule
und reden dort im unterricht andere
suchen sich vielleicht einen tandem
partner und andere versuchen andere
methoden und dafür haben wir heute einen
gast eingeladen willkommen robin sehr
schön dich zu sehen
schön dich zu sehen wir haben uns vor
kurzer zeit kennengelernt und wir wollen
heute mit dir darüber sprechen wie man
die deutsche oder überhaupt sprachpraxis
bekommen kann und zwar auf eine ganz
besondere weise nämlich indem man mit
sich selbst spricht wie du hast ja
deutsch gelernt vor allem dadurch dass
du mit dir selber sprichst seit wann
hast du denn deutsch gelernt oder wie
lange hast du deutsch gelernt
ja also das war im jahr 2015 also vor
ungefähr fünf jahren habe ich also
angefangen
und ja das ist das war eine schwierige
zeit in mein leben und ich wollte also
neue möglichkeiten im leben in
deutschland suchen
und ja also ich hab nur sechs wochen
zeit also
auf den umzug nach deutschland
vorzubereiten
noch vor zubereitet nicht so nicht so
lange und ja aus sich in deutschland
ankam hatte ich einen grundlegendes
sprachniveau entwickelt also erkannt ich
konnte alles auf deutsch machen ist
nicht perfekt deutsch und ja also ich
habe nur zwei moden zwei monaten in
deutschland gewohnt und danach habe ich
nicht so viel deutsch gesprochen oder
gelernt und rezent habe ich schon wieder
also mein deutsch studieren angefangen
und ja wir sind wir hier
letzte woche haben wir ja zum ersten mal
telefoniert und da hast du mir gesagt
wir haben dort auch deutsch gesprochen
und du hast mir gesagt das war dein
erstes gespräch auf deutsch seit fünf
jahren
und das ist echt ziemlich krass weil du
sprichst echt ziemlich flüssig deutsch
und hat seit fünf jahren gar kein
deutsch gesprochen und damals nur zwei
monate in deutschland gelebt und da
stellt sich mir natürlich die frage wie
geht das wie hast du das gemacht mit wem
sprichst du deutsch ja also ich also ich
glaube viele leute sagen dass man man
muss ganz oft und ganz früh mit
muttersprache sprechen und ich finde das
ist also es gibt oft diese diese
betonung darauf na also mit anderen zu
sprechen
und ja ich sehe es an ich das sehe ich
anders
persönlich was für mich funktioniert und
da also nach in deutschland gewohnt habe
habe ich nicht wirklich auf deutsch
gesprochen
ich habe ich hatte einige kurze periode
deutsch zu lernen aber nicht nicht so
richtig und ja also für mich ich bin
ziemlich schüchtern
diese fördert für wirklich schwierig ich
bin ziemlich schüchtern und besonders
wenn ich nicht so viel sagen kann wenn
ich liegt meiner idee gut erklären kann
und also ich sehe ich sehe es bei mir
selbst eine eines grundlegende eines
group ein grundlegendes sprachniveau
entwickeln und danach bin ich natürlich
mehr aktiv aktiver also gelegenheiten zu
finden oder zu zumachen mit anderen zu
sprechen
das heißt du lernst deutsch oder du
kriegst deine sprachpraxis ganz alleine
wie funktioniert das denn ja also ich
für mich das wichtigste ist spaß zu
machen und ich glaube dass viele leute
ein bisschen also mit der idee mit mit
sich selbst zu sprechen nicht so
wohlfühlen
aber es ist die die idee glaube ich und
also ich habe einige methode entwickelt
ja bin mit mir selbst zu sprechen und
mit mir selbst also spaß machen
also ich weiß nicht wie man das sagt
aber aber ja und spaß zu haben was zu
haben genau genau und also ich habe
einige methode wie ich habe prozent eine
video gemacht über meine podcast
interview methode aber ich habe einige
methode und ja also ich mit mir selbst
üben und das macht viel spaß
das ist witzig weil so haben wir uns
kennengelernt du hast ein video gemacht
wie du mit podcast hören deutsch lernst
und dort hast du einen beispiel podcast
genommen und das war zufällig unser
podcast sondern wirklich sehr sehr cool
eine zuhörerin von uns die auch
gleichzeitig seine zuschauerinnen ist
hat uns dieses video geschickt und ich
war total beeindruckt in diesem video
hast du erzählt dass du dir du hörst
beim podcast nicht nur zu sondern
stellst dir auch vor dass du ein gast
bist in dem podcast gelohnt dass manuel
und ich dir dann fragen stellen und du
mit diskutierst genau diese diese fragen
von der imaginären carré diebe
antwortest du dann selber für dich zu
hause genommen
ja genau ist also ich liebe podcasten
und ich glaube dass die meisten leute
also geschichte mögen also für mich
liebe podcasten und also ja ich nehme
ein 1 1 folgen einer folge und ich nehme
meine lieblings teile und ich
konstruiere also meine eigene antwort
nach eine frage und also ja ich nehme
eine frage und in dieser beispiel war es
die sein
sowas ist die sein warum ist es
interessant warum ist es wichtig und ja
also ich nehme diese frage und am montag
frage ich mich und ja dann erst erst ein
tag ist ein bisschen schwierig ich muss
sehr viele wörter versuchen vielleicht
wird die sein vielleicht gibt es viele
wörter das ich nicht verstehe nicht
nicht weiß aber ich frage mich diese
frage jeden tag für einige eine woche
und also am zweiten tag 3 tag es ist
mehr und mehr einfach es ist einfach ein
einfacher und am fünften sechsten tag
ist es so einfach dass sich total eine
andere antwort gebe und ja es ist sehr
cool weil nach einer woche ich wirklich
eine gute antwort kann und das ist sehr
sehr cool dann könntest
dann könntest du bei uns im podcast
dabei sein und auch antworten das wäre
schön
und danach und und danach habe ich eine
andere frage
und was ist sehr cool ist das im leben
als ich mit dir wirklichen leben spreche
vielleicht habe ich drei oder vier topix
topix dass ich sehr wohl fühle und er
kann mit dir über diese topix sprechen
und vielleicht die konversation die
gespräche wenn wir in andere gehe
anderer direktion gehe aber ich kann ein
bisschen dass sie direkt nach objekt das
sie verrückt machen ja genau und also ja
nach einem monat zwei monaten habe ich
viele topix dass ich wirklich eine gute
gespräch kann und ich liebe das
das ist cool und das ist ja so du hast
auch ein video darüber gemacht dieses
video heißt scientific foreign languages
mitautor king to people also in diesem
video erzählst du diese methode noch mal
genauer das video könnt ihr euch
übrigens hier oder hier anschauen wenn
ihr das mal wollt das ist also ein
längeres video wo du genau erklärt wie
du durch das sprechen mit dir selber
sprachpraxis bekommst kann es denn
wirklich jeder machen ist das eine gute
idee für jede person oder gibt es leute
oder was sind die hürden die man dabei
haben könnte es ist ja bestimmt nicht
jeder mensch nicht jeder mensch findet
diese idee total attraktiv mit sich
selber zu reden den ganzen tag sagen
also genau also nicht unbedingt ist es
nicht unbedingt perfekt für alle und ich
sage nie also du musst also so machen
dies ist die beste weg zu lernen
aber wie ich gesagt habe ich glaube das
ist ist die idee mit die mit der idee
sich selbst zu sprechen
dass viele leute nicht so wohl fühlen
und ich glaube das alles auch wenn wir
kreativ sein können dass das kann sehr
viel spaß machen und zum beispiel
vielleicht viele leute nicht so viel
podcast in mögen aber sie sie lieben
easy german video das ist ein bisschen
unterschiedlich ne danke und also man
kann auch das macht man kam zum beispiel
also weil in einer folge von the german
es gibt viele viele antworten die
gleiche frage also ich kann mein
lieblingsteil nehmen vielleicht eine
person einer kuhle wird sagt aber eine
andere person eine gute idee um würzt
oder so weiter und so fort und ich kann
meine eigene antwort konstruieren
aber vielleicht einige leute also
blieben also ich kann ein buch nehmen
die weiter ein sehr einfacher burg oder
ein wirklich ein buch für native und ich
kann ein kapitel nehmen
und ich kann mir fragen also okay es
gibt cafés gibt manuel ist janosch diese
charakter und diese kapitel war von der
perspektiv und kari aber wie es wie ist
es mit manu wie würde ich von seinem
perspektiv die geschichte erzählen oder
soja und also es gibt viele viele viele
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten also
diese praktikums zu wackeln also ja ist
nicht unbedingt für alle perfekt aber
ich glaube das kann sehr nützlich sein
und ja es ist immer so
ja es ist eigentlich es klingt so
einfach aber ich muss sagen dass ich
auch in diesen zeiten wo ich richtig
selber richtig motiviert sprachen
gelernt haben da habe ich das auch
gemacht ich habe in meinem kopf immer
imaginäre dialoge gehabt und natürlich
hast du
von alleine nicht so viele themen also
es gibt nur eine begrenzte anzahl von
fragen die du so spontan hast aber wenn
du dir eine methode aus denkt und sagt
okay diese woche ist mein thema design
oder dieser thema diese woche ist mein
thema essen und dann gehst du so
verschiedene situationen oder
perspektiven durch ich glaube das ist
eine super gute idee ist und vor allem
ist es eine idee die du immer machen
kannst sie ist flexibel du kannst das
machen ohne viel geld haben zu müssen
und genau
ja es klingt so einfach und ich glaube
aber trotzdem dass es für viele leute
nicht die erste option ist man denkt
immer oh ich muss einen kurs machen ich
muss geld ausgeben
ich muss leute kennenlernen wie treffe
ich leute und dann denkt man oh das sind
so viele hürden die ich überwinden muss
das ist vielleicht ein bisschen
demotivierend auch manchmal ist fließend
eine sprache zu lernen und ich finde das
sehr beeindruckend
darin weil du hast ja jetzt ein paar
monate insgesamt deutsch gelernt oder
sogar nur ein paar wochen und sprichst
einfach super fließend deutsch und das
ist einfach eine super gute basis um
dann zum beispiel in deutschland mit
muttersprachlern zu sprechen und dann
richtig zu einem super schnell zu einem
richtig richtig guten niveau zu kommen
genau ja es ist sehr cool ich glaube
dass dieses gespräch ist ein bisschen
eine gute beispiel weil ja wenn ich
diese video gemacht habe
die leute aber das ist nicht das ist
quatsch die du kannst nicht wirklich mit
anderen sprechende aber diese hier ist
meine zweite also echt gespräch und auch
ich bin auch ein bisschen überrascht
das will das würde so sprechen kann ich
ich ich kann mir vorstellen dass so
viele fehler gemacht habe aber das macht
spaß und wir wir haben ein echter
gespräch gehabt und das ist sehr sehr
schön
ich glaube ich absolut es war ein sehr
schönes gespräch und ich hoffe dass das
eine motivation ist für alle von euch da
draußen wenn ihr unseren podcast hört
oder unsere videos hört und vielleicht
eine methode sucht wie ihr schneller
sprachpraxis bekommt versucht das mal
guckt euch robbins video an wir werden
deinen kanal hier unten verlinken
dort gibt es auch einige oder viele
andere nützliche tipps zum sprachen
lernen und dann stellt euch einfach ganz
lange vor wie ihr mit uns imaginär
sprecht und irgendwann tut ihr das dann
wirklich weil wir uns dann vielleicht
bei einem mieter trifft oder auf einer
bei einer anderen gelegenheit mit und
sprecht oder eben mit anderen deutschen
und plötzlich könnt ihr genau so
fließend sprechen wie robin ein gutes
vorbild pistor event vielen dank
dankeschön robin dass du dabei warst
guckt euch mal seinen kanal an und
stellt uns fragen und wenn ihr fragen
habt dann machen wir vielleicht noch mal
ein video demnächst hat mich sehr
gefreut ich auch dass magath bis bald
[Applaus]
[Musik]